why do we care about circles we care
about circles because circles are
awesome there are beautiful and simple
shapes and they're full of as you can
see them they're full of symmetry right
they are the quintessentially
symmetrical object their reflection
asymmetrical their rotationally
symmetrical they've got an infinite
number of axes of symmetry if you wanted
to have a symmetrical object this is it
okay and that symmetry will result in a
whole bunch of properties and we're
going to prove much of them okay so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to run
through this list we're going to prove
each of these properties but so that you
get a sense of how this works and not
get bogged down in all the sort of Gea's
and technicalities I'm not going to
write out full and proper proofs you
guys know how to prove colored triangles
you know how to prove similar triangles
parallel lines all that kind of thing so
I'm not going to labor with those points
I'm just going to have a bit of fun with
you okay so the first one there is about
chords actually the first three about
chords so let me draw this picture for
you and then we'll try and explain the
words that go into those little gaps I
apologize that the gaps are small I was
just desperate to include this all on
one page so that's why I've squeezed it
in so you'll need to write small on your
first circle what I'd like to do in
addition to having your pair of
compasses is get a ruler out get a ruler
out and with your ruler I would like you
to join up any two points on the
circumference of the circle I'm going to
use a lot of language here's some which
you know like circumference others of
which I'm going to have to introduce
okay so find two spots like say here and
here and go ahead join them up with your
rule on
okay
now once you've done that I also like
you to measure it while you're ruling it
find out its length because I told you
to pick any two points on the
circumference maybe they're very close
together it's like a centimeter maybe
they're quite far apart maybe they're
you know five six enemies I don't know
how big your circle is but that's one of
the wonderful things about circle
properties that no matter what circle
you drew no matter what interval you
drew this property I'm going to show you
is going to work okay
now by the way you already know what a
circumference is I want to tell you what
this particular interval is called it's
called a chord so a chord like in music
a chord is a an interval that joins two
points on the circumference that's all
the corners okay now remember I asked
you to measure this chord okay my court
happens to be obviously larger than
yours 42 centimeters goodness that's a
big chord what I want you to do for
whatever length you drew is draw another
chord somewhere else that's the same
length
can you do that just find anywhere else
on the circle draw a chord of the same
length
now since these chords are the same
length we might as well mark the min as
equal 8 so I've got my two little dashes
there okay now we need to add a few more
constructions arms here there is one
point in a circle that is the most
important point of all of them it's what
defines the circle that point of course
is the center right so you need to find
your center there's lots of ways to do
that I mean because you use the compass
you probably made a tiny little mark on
your page so you can use that another
way to find the center is to notice that
every diameter of the circle every
diameter of the circle passes through
the center right now the diameter if you
notice I'm using this language the
diameter is a cord it's not just any
cord it's the longest cord you can make
in a circle right so another way that
you can find the center because maybe
you didn't use a pair of compasses is to
take your ruler and measure a cross
until you find the longest possible cord
that you can draw right so for example
the longest cord I could draw is about
67 centimeters right if I move the ruler
anywhere else I would get a shorter cord
so once you've got the longest possible
cord you found the diameter and you can
put the centre right in the middle okay
now these two cords they form angles at
the centre the fancy word for form in
this context of circle geometry is the
word subtend you can see it there as the
in the first line there so what I want
to do with your ruler is to join up from
these two cords join outlines at the
center to subdue an angle I'll show you
what it looks like on line here that
angle there is the angle subtended at
the centre by the cord okay and you're
going to get a similar one down here
okay so I have subtended two angles at
the centre each on a different chord now
it's really sort of cumbersome to say
this chord in that chord so I am now
going to give things some names by
convention we almost always name the
center of the circle oh just like the
origin on a Cartesian plane and then we
can call these chords whatever we like
maybe we'll call them PQ and RS so what
you've got and these are the first two
words I think on the the sheet what
you've got are equal chords equal chords
you see them right now what you should
find is that the angles at the center
they clearly look equal don't they I
mean if you've actually measured it out
they must be okay now I've said before
when we were looking at geometry last
week you need more than just oh it looks
you know it sort of ish close to each
other we want to prove that okay now I
want you to have a look this is a very
simple property that's why it's the
first one you guys have enough knowledge
in your mind to prove conclusively that
the angles have to be the same they're
not just coincidentally they have to be
anyone who suggests what we could do
yeah education okay so see these pair of
triangles triangle p oq' and triangle
are s i can prove that they are whoops
doesn't that's okay I can prove that the
relationship between them is that they
are congruent right they are exactly the
same triangle I just spun it around
right and the reason why I suggested is
s s s but how would I know that I'm not
worried about writing it down I just
want you to talk it through with me say
yeah okay great it's a circle the
quintessential property about a circle
is that anywhere from the circle to the
circumference is the same length so this
length and this length are the same and
going on this length and this length are
the same they're all radii so I would
say for instance if I were constructing
a full proof for this i'd say PA equals
R reason radii
similarly because I don't have to
restate the reasoning qo equals s Oh
done and the chords of course are equal
that's how we started this so I've got
my three pairs of sides if they're
congruent then of course I know that
these corresponding angles must also be
equal they're not vertically opposite by
the way I know they sort of look like it
but they don't have to be I could draw
them so they even overlap like this
something like this if those two are
equal so that's a weird-looking
situation there right but if I've got
this chord and this chord being equal
then I need a new color hmm let's have a
look here is the angle subtended by one
chord at the center and here is the
angle subtended by the other they're
clearly not vertically opposite they're
on top of each other for goodness sake
but I've got the same congruent
triangles here as I did here and no
matter what diagram you've drawn you've
got Congress rhinos as well so therefore
first property equal chords you can fill
this in sorry you're gonna need to write
small equal chords September Co angles
at the center